the three Muslims today I am joined with
Dr Dennis McDonald how you doing today
Rami thank you Dr Dennis McDonald is a
honestly in my opinion a very esteemed
scholar of the New Testament uh he
received his PhD from Harvard University
and has taught New Testament and
Christian Origins at various colleges
and universities around America and has
served as the Director of the institute
for Antiquity and Christianity at the
Claremont Graduate University here in
California he's the author of many books
including the gospels of Homer
mythologizing Jesus and his most recent
publication right here
Hefty and beautiful one synopsis of Epic
tragedy and the gospels so Dr Dennis
McDonald first I want to ask a question
about some of your work because it's
very interesting
um literary
mimesis Nemesis Nemesis I always get
that wrong literary Nemesis so you have
essentially pioneered a new method of
understanding how the gospels in the New
Testament were put together how
Christians uh christology of Jesus kind
of develops over time and you call this
literary Nemesis could you explain what
that is and why it's so important to the
New Testament well Nemesis was very well
known in ancient education Rami yeah um
it's the way people learn to write so
quintillion for example the the famous
Latin rhetorician was when he trained
people to write he's he would say things
like if you want to write history read
Herodotus and imitate Herodotus or
xenophan or in Latin you could do the
same thing with Livy or if you wanted to
write rhetoric you could look at the
great Greek rhetoricians in Cicero and
so
um these there were no instructions on
how to do Nemesis although there were
some guidelines occasionally for example
if you want to avoid plagiarism
so one way to do that is to imitate more
than one model at a time usually no more
than three because your reader is not
going to be able to follow what you're
doing in Nemesis so Nemesis actually has
a cultural function that is it's to
establish for the reader
an alternative social reality from the
one that is articulated in the model
so Homer is the most important model
that was used in in Greek composition
and it also was a cultural icon if the
Greeks had a Bible it would have been
the homeric epics
and in order for Jews Christians in
certain marginal
Greco-Roman religions to establish their
identity they had to bounce off the
homeric epics in order to establish that
identity
usually to show that Jesus or Moses or
other leaders were more compassionate
than Dionysus or asclepius
and so on
and so the Nemesis was everywhere in
ancient education and another part of
that and this was especially the case
apparently for
um training people for the Law Court
was something called synchrosis and
simply means a comparison but it's
usually a comparison of two characters
both of whom are virtuous but your
character is more virtuous than someone
else wow so
um you're in a law court and you want to
say yes my opponents
my client's opponent has virtues but my
client has different virtues and
stronger ones and it's a form of
encomium so you could see how that'd be
useful in the Law Court yeah but it's
also true in religious discourse so
early Christians were interested in
saying that Jesus was more compassionate
than Moses wow or to say that Jesus was
at least as powerful as Elijah and
Alicia
but the uh authors of the New Testament
are also doing that to say that Jesus's
death is more heroic than hectors
because Hector dies and Jesus rises from
the dead I see or
um yes Dionysus can turn water into wine
but Jesus can turn water into wine as
well and produce water in the wilderness
for the Samaritan woman so one has this
impulse in
um Greek writing but also it appears in
Latin as well think of Virgil's in need
Virgil's need is an extended Nemesis of
the homeric epics and it uses syncreases
to show that Aeneas is more important
than the Greek Heroes especially Ulysses
wow
um so
um this is it's in the wind and it's
surprising that
um Scholars of the New Testament did not
recognize that earlier
so would you say that I've founded
Nemesis criticism and so on I'm only
trying to articulate a methodology that
is recognizable from the ancient world
and apply it to texts that are written
from that world to see if it makes any
sense my first discovery in this way was
not about the Gospels it was about the
acts of Andrew of all things where
Andrew whose name means manliness and
who's a fisherman and so he sails the
sea and has these these issues
um is more philosophically sophisticated
than Socrates he's more powerful than
Heracles he
um can
exercise demoniacs like Heracles and so
on so it goes on and on and I worked on
an edition of the acts of Andrew for 10
years because at that point it hadn't
come out in an addition
and at the same time wrote a
christianizing homer but Rami at the
time I thought that the acts of Andrew
was unique wow it's actually
characteristic of much
um ancient literature wow both among
Jews pagans and Christians so uh there
have been our wonderful books written on
for example euripides Dionysus in the in
the Buckeye and how Jews Christians and
uh and pagans sorry for pagans I don't I
know that's a loaded term but a non-jews
non-christians
um were trying to show that their Heroes
were more compassionate than euripides
Dionysus who was really a jerk
wow so okay so so this method or more so
what we understand using this method is
that there are certain people who will
take a prior story of some
epic heroic figure who does all these
amazing things and they'll have their
character who they want to portray as
better than this person so they'll mimic
certain maybe lines or an event certain
um happenings from that person's life
onto this new person but they'll add
specific details to make them better
exactly you've said it better than I did
so for example I know that the Q
document many people don't believe
there's a q document the Lost gospel
yeah but I'm sure that there was and it
appears to be an imitation of
Deuteronomy
to make Jesus more compassionate than
Moses wow so in fact it says the law and
the prophets were until John the Baptist
after that is the kingdom of God I see
um the first words in the Q document
these are the words of uh of Jesus and
John the Baptist is in the wilderness
preaching repentance how does this test
Septuagint of Deuteronomy begin these
are the logo the words of Moses that he
spoke to Israel in the wilderness and
those parallels go on and on there are
citations quotations from Deuteronomy
their allusions to Deuteronomy and Jesus
is the more compassionate Moses so this
is a beautiful example of literary
Nemesis because you have an imitation of
Deuteronomy yeah to function as
synchrosis to show that Jesus is
superior to Moses and more compassionate
wow so so what if someone hears that and
they're like well
maybe he just was you know maybe he just
was more compassionate than Moses and he
was this great figure you know Moses was
cool and all but he's Jesus so what
would you say to that is this a very
good observation Rami and to make a
literary judgment is not the same as
making a historical judgment yeah but
the two can be linked
in this way if we are talking about
let's say the the Moses of the Q
document and you could say the same
thing with Mo Matthew does the same
thing yeah
you can say okay maybe there really was
a Jesus who was an alternative Moses
I'm not in a position to say there
wasn't
I am in a position to say you don't need
a historical Moses to make that
to to tell this story yeah
and when other parts of the story are so
outrageous I'm likely to say
um it's really naive to think there's a
historical basis to this other than
something very general that Jesus was
challenging Jewish law to stand up for
social Outsiders yeah yeah very
beautifully said and we actually are
going to touch a little bit more on the
Q document and a little more of those
outrageous events that are maybe just
non-historical or historically
implausible so
what does this exactly have to do with
the gospels I know you mentioned the
gospel of Cuba when you look at Mark
Matthew Luke and John how is literally
sorry Nemesis used Nemesis is all over
the gospel of Mark yeah and it's hard to
read a single story in Mark that doesn't
have a homeric or an Athenian tragedy
analogy or antecedent
um I don't even know where to start the
death of Jesus in Mark is it like the
death of Hector wow
um he does not drink wine before he dies
um there's a taunting
um uh you know destroyer of the temple
save yourself and so on Jesus then says
on the cross my God my God why have you
forsaken me Hector knows that Apollo has
forsaken him and he laments it and even
so he dies heroically when he dies he
shouts out because his soul is going to
the netherworld that's what Jesus he
dies with the shout three women are
watching Jesus die from a distance three
women lead the laments for
um for Hector wow you have the um the
shrouding and the anointing for death
not by Mary of Nazareth but by Mary
Magdalene who's an alternative to the
mother you have Joseph of Vera mathia by
the way Arimathea means excellent
discipleship
rescuing the body of Jesus the same way
that the father of Hector Priam had to
rescue the body of Hector from
um from Achilles the difference of the
syncreases of course as Jesus rises from
the dead and Hector does not one of my
favorite examples is the Garrison
demoniac story where Jesus and counters
of caveman lives in the in the tombs
and nobody can can control him
and Jesus sails there with his 12 men
that's what Odysseus does 12 men sail
and a ship they've encountered the
Cyclops polyphemus
Odysseus takes care of him by blinding
his eye and stealing his sheep jesus
takes care of the cavemen by exercising
the demons wow and he does so like
Cersei turning soldiers into swine and
then the swine get drowned that's how
Odysseus is the crew end up after this
they they drown because of an incident
at thrinakia
um the the parallels go on and on
and in these cases
in some of them I mean it's quite clear
that there was no Garrison demoniac but
it is likely that Jesus was an exorcist
because we have evidence of that
widespread in the ancient world of
people religious characters were
understood to combat the demonic
but um the story is playful and is
trying to say that Jesus is more
compassionate than Odysseus and Virgil
does the damn same thing in the Aeneid
where Ania stumbles onto the island of
polyphemus and
Odysseus had left one of his Greek
soldiers behind and Ania shows what a
Menchie is by taking this stranded
Soldier aboard his ship in making him a
part of the Trojan
evacuation of Troy so it goes on and on
Rami I wish we had five hours and chat
but and the acts the apostles the same
thing happens yeah yeah and I actually I
do want to touch on that a bit later but
um unfortunately we don't have five
hours but what we do have is your
publication synopsis of Epic tragedy and
the gospels
um are all of these points and more in
this publication oh and much more wow
this is
570 pages that now is being sold by
Amazon at cheaper than I can buy it with
the author's cost it's under 18 wow and
if you have Amazon Prime you can get it
for free shipping wow and you're not
going to find a bargain like that and
the reason the cost is controlled is
that I am Nemesis press and I was able
to keep the cost down by self-publishing
so um really there's no ex I mean you
can't buy a
um something for your bird feeder that
is
um as cheap as that yeah absolutely
absolutely and for the reference book
that it is for all the points that it
hits uh for all the work that went into
it you know translating uh you translate
everything yourself as well and um I I
you know when I popped it open I saw all
the the syncreases the comparison
between all these different you know the
gospels and all these different epics as
well so you know it's it's tremendous
honestly I would say anyone uh Muslim or
Christian or you know really anyone with
any belief if you're interested in the
Old Testament or so the New Testament
the life of Jesus or you know
Greco-Roman literature at all I would
say you have to buy a copy of this book
and look into it the parallels are
astonishing Rami you're so kind and I I
want to thank you for making this work
available to Muslim viewers
because I actually think it opens up new
avenues for inter-religious dialogue
where we can deprive certain Christians
of the notion that these things are all
transmitted by God and their
um they don't have
parallels in other religions and so on
so we can talk about owning our own
religions yeah and get along absolutely
100 and Interfaith dialogues actually as
a side note something that Islam really
encourages you know it says in the Quran
God tells us to you know politely and
kindly debate with the people and if
that you know if you claim this and that
about God and so on and so forth you
have to bring your proof your evidence
and if evidence is brought against you
then you know uh and vice versa it
really shows that maybe you don't have
much to stand on well you know and it
shows that there are places in the Quran
that are huge truly humanistic yeah
um and Universal and that's what this
discussion is about I think absolutely
100 and I think as we unravel some of
the the points and and I asked some of
these questions people the viewers are
really going to understand you know why
we had to have this conversation and why
your work is so important so
just so I make sure I understand the
literary Nemesis in terms of the New
Testament and the gospels you have these
trained Greek authors essentially who
were Anonymous we don't know exactly who
they were
um who are not eyewitnesses of Jesus
correct that would appear to be the case
yes okay and so they wrote the gospels
through whatever sources they had and
whatever they heard in the conjecture
and all that and they also had
implemented stories of previous you know
um epics and and heroes like
um like Homer
Odysseus you know these epic great men
that did you know lived honorable and
amazing lives and they took their story
said hmm I like how Odysseus did this
I'm going to make Jesus do the same
thing and one point that I heard from
one of your previous podcasts that I
thought was very interesting is it's not
just the parallels that are important
but the differences because exactly yeah
the the differences highlight exactly
what the author is trying trying to tell
you right that's right that's that's
exactly right in other words sometimes
Nemesis is sympathetic yeah it's to show
that your character has the same virtues
as the model but more often that not
it's what we call agonistic Nemesis that
is it's to show that my hero is
surpassing your hero yeah and often it
does so to establish new social
identities for the Earth in the case of
early Christians
um
um over against the Roman Empire yeah
but it's it really is almost Universal
that we have imitation going on to
establish new identities and so on I
wanted to to say one more thing about
what you mentioned yeah New Testament
scholars in the past and unfortunately
still are stuck with a methodology
called redaction criticism redaction is
simply a German word for
um editing and it reduces the gospel
authors to scribes who are editing
sources and you use the word sources but
you were very wise Rami in saying but
they also use literary models that these
gospel authors are not scribes yeah they
can scribe they can edit but they also
are truly artists yeah that are creating
something off of models and they
sometimes do sympathetic do it
sympathetically yeah but often they do
it competitively
and this rivalry actually was taught in
Greek schools too it was in Greek it was
called zelosis yeah where we get the
word Zealot it means the Rivalry I see
and um yeah and so it's a part of this
the syncreases that's amazing honestly
so I really like the point they
mentioned that they are artists you know
because you know this begs the question
how could they become you know confused
or persuaded by these stories but it's
not that per se they just have a
narrative a point they need to get
across and they do it in a very elegant
and beautiful way in a way that you know
readers can wreck let me ask you a
question yeah
don't you think there's a difference
between understand myth understanding
myth as non-historical falsehood and
myth understood as a part of a cultural
argument yeah
and the problem that people have often
with mythology is that they think it
means that it's unhistorical and it's
not true yeah no mythology is about what
makes things true yeah
so I don't believe that Jesus rose from
the dead yeah so for me that's a myth
and it's a marvelous myth yeah even if I
don't believe that it happened it it
means that the authors are affirming
life yeah and they're saying that there
is there ought to be hope yeah and many
religions have something like that so I
think that's a very interesting point so
there are underlying philosophical
truths right so let's say that you know
people believe life is good right
um and and living a heroic life is even
better so to exaggerate this truth they
will use a story that perhaps the story
in the details in and of themselves are
not true per se but the overall message
they're giving is the is the truth
there's a difference between historical
fact and Truth yeah and Truth is uh more
important than historical fact in many
ways okay so could you give me an
example of a a Truth Versus historical
fact and how they differ
um I don't think we know how Jesus died
except that he was crucified
um do we know if he was courageous do we
know if he was in agony did we know that
he was angry did we do we know that he
was guilty of something we don't know
yeah but the narrative about him is
um makes him
consciously courageous I say and uh
defying death because he had a
conviction presumably about the
rightness of what he was proclaiming I
see so
um I don't know how Jesus died but I
know that the story is compelling yeah
absolutely and that's something that I I
really do appreciate about the the
gospels the passion narrative it's a
very touching story it is very beautiful
and I can see why Christians you know
are so
um so
just attached to it because it really is
a beautiful story and I think Mark is
the First Gospel you take correct or
first out of the four the the first of
the fourth that's right but also you
know The Passion of The Death of
Socrates in Plato's Fido is so moving
and I wouldn't be surprised that
especially in Luke that Luke's version
of death of Jesus is informed by The
Death of Socrates oh wow so another form
of literary Nemesis then yeah wow wow
that's tremendous so it seems to be the
case that Mark who is the first writer
out of the fore in the New Testament
gospels really
had a story had a narrative had a a you
know almost beautiful message and needed
to portray Jesus as someone who knew he
was going to be crucified for Humanity a
um a Beyond just a good doer a you know
the Son of God someone who came for all
of humanity someone who is more epic
than Odysseus and one example of
literary Nemesis that you had talked
about before is you know you're a Clea
and the anointing of Jesus yeah that's a
famous one yeah it's um I've heard it so
many times and every time I hear it it's
just it it really boggles my mind
because I think it hits a lot of the
points of literary Nemesis so
um if I do recall correctly Odysseus
after coming back from a long journey
um it disguised himself because he's
like I don't want people to recognize me
if they do they're gonna kill me so in
this disguise he goes you know basically
back home and his his childhood wet
nurse and and Nanny basically
um was told to anoint him and to wash
him and so so on and so forth so she
does and in washing his feet she notices
his childhood scar so she recognizes him
and he says don't tell anyone because if
they find out they're going to kill me
and then you go to Jesus and what is the
name of this this woman in the Odyssey
you're a Clea and what does that mean
your Clea is built of two words
um Yura I think or if I pronounce it
right means uh to Renown and Clea means
far and wide yeah so she's famous yeah
yeah so tell me about the gospel story
so now you fast forward to what Mark
writes about Jesus and he's being uh
essentially he's with his companions
he's with his disciples and a lady who I
don't think she's named but yeah so
she's not named she comes and she
anoints Jesus you know by I believe
pouring perfumes and stuff over his head
and there are some details in between
about what the disciples said and what
he said about her but the main point is
that she anointed him because Jesus
claims that she recognizes he will die
so now you have this lady who anoints
him because she's the only one who
recognizes him and the beauty and the
difference is that Mark makes a note
that she knows him because he's going to
die which shows what that the the the
the difference is supposed to stand out
that this man is going to die and then
he says in what she has done will be
proclaimed wherever the gospels Proclaim
yeah in other words she'll have far and
wide renowned wow now in the Gospel of
John and in the uh before that in Luke
the Risen Jesus demonstrates who he is
by exposing his scar
exposing his wounds wow so it's the same
recognition the Greece called an Anakin
rhesus but it's uh it's dramatic
recognition of the true identity of
someone yeah wow and um this is just one
example of you'd say many throughout all
four gospels it's just it's really
surprising how um how often it appears
wow wow that is that is amazing and
again they're not doing it out of any
any Mal intent or maliciousness no it's
just a form of creative art and
portraying not trying to deceive the
reader you're trying to edify the reader
yeah to say
um there is hope and but one other
reason that I think is really important
to raise around me is Mark is writing
after the Jewish War and what a tragedy
that was yeah and he wants a hero who
also is a heroic martyr
and who can ask of his followers if they
take up their own crosses and that they
look forward to some kind of redemption
by God for their sufferings and in order
to do that it's helpful to have models
from the homeric epics where you have
people like Odysseus who suffer before
they get home yeah they're eager to get
to their their home or Hector who dies
heroically even though he knows he's
outgunned
yeah so is is the literary Mimis is
something that let's say like for the
Layman Christian who's reading the Bible
reading the gospels and they're in awe
of these beautiful stories do they know
that these things didn't really happen
to Jesus but there are stories that were
put onto him no and not even Scholars
know it wow that's why I wanted to have
a reference work yeah basically this is
an encyclopedia if you read the first 18
Pages that's all you need for an
introduction to this it not only gives
the methodology but it also tells you
how the whole thing ends the general
conclusion is in the first 20 pages and
then you can use it as a reference work
like an encyclopedia you have a passage
that you're interested in a character
you want to investigate this will give
suggestions of what models might have
been out there yeah now one of the
reasons that Nemesis is so long in
coming to us
is
ignorance about homeric epics
and about Athenian tragedy yeah and you
have to be intentional about stepping
outside of at the Greek Roman world into
the ancient Greek world yeah and
stepping there means you have to
translate a different kind of Greek
Archaic Greek is not quite named Greek
by any stretch yeah and um the homeric
epics uh obviously were written 800
years earlier they're written in a
different language
um they are polytheistic so on the
surface it would seem to be that the New
Testament has very little in common with
them and this certainly is true of most
Christian lay people when they read
their Bibles yeah they have cultural
Amnesia about the antecedents yeah and
so the um when people read the Bible
they're prone to do one of two things
they're prone to say well if if this is
the the document of our people this must
have happened so you compare it not to
other literature but to what you're you
think historically must have happened
more liberal oriented Christians are
willing to say there must be some kind
of spiritual truth behind these stories
instead of cultural exchange yeah and so
there's all kinds of Pious
misreadings of these stories as though
you know it means we ought to love each
other or
um whatever well yes we should love each
other but that's not what the story is
saying the story is trying to establish
a cultural identity it actually has
punched to it and you don't get the
punch unless you know what they're
punching that's that's a very good way
of putting it you don't know wow wow you
don't know what the punches unless you
know what they're punching that's right
very beautifully said all right amazing
so I have a few uh quick fire questions
for you in regards to you know the just
the what you believe to be the truth
surrounding the New Testament and the
gospel so people assume that the order
of the the books and specifically the
gospels in the New Testament are
chronological but what order were the
gospels actually written in oh the ones
that we have in the New Testament surely
were written as Mark the first then
Matthew then Luke and x and then the
Gospel of John I see so so acts was
actually written before the Gospel of
John yes okay and uh do you agree with
the opinion that Mark was written
sometime in 65 A.D and then John being
the last one was written maybe around 90
95 80. no no those dates are too early
all of them too early um I would say
that the the uh the author of The Gospel
of Mark is writing after the war
and
um it it could be it probably was soon
after the war but the war is not over
till 70. wow and so then I would say
that it was probably mid 70s something
like that the Gospel of John in my view
wasn't written until about 1 30. oh wow
1 30. so and you know this brings a very
interesting point that I want to get to
but before I ask that question I want to
ask a lot of Scholars and I think you do
this in your book as well kind of
they they authorize the Gospel of John
compared to the the other three gospels
in the New Testament why is that what
makes it different from others
boy the I'll try to be brief because you
wanted to pick five questions
the Gospel of John apparently was
composed in three stages okay the first
stage is what I call the dionysian
gospel this is where you get the
parallels to euripides bakay the second
is what I call the anti-jewish gospel
this is where you get the hostility to
Judaism you're of the Father the devil
he was a murderer from the beginning and
so on this is where you get most of the
citations of the Bible in a comparison
of Jesus favorably to Moses for example
yeah the last part the the last version
was a diplomatic version and it's called
I call it the Beloved disciple gospel
because the Beloved disciple appears
only in this final stratum now each of
those has a different relationship to
the synoptic gospels but the synoptic
gospels are known at each stage
the first is to supplement the synoptic
gospels the second is to compete with
them and the third is to make nice with
them uh if the the dionism got the
Beloved disciple gospel Ends by saying I
suppose the heavens would not be enough
to to have all the things that would be
written about Jesus but the Beloved
disciple is the one we like so we like
this gospel but it recognizes the others
and it actually recognizes Peter is the
uh the The Shepherd of the flock after
Jesus's death but the first one and this
is going on more than you wanted perhaps
but I think there's one other thing to
say about John that's important yeah
remember we talked about Mark and how
Jesus is a martyr and how he expects
sacrifices by his from his followers
but Dionysus is the one who throws
parties he returns water into wine
um he is creates The Joy of Sex
and um how do how will this Christian
Community compete with dionysian
religion and keep its young people if
um if Dionysus can show people a good
time and Jesus can't
so it's a way and it and it starts out
that way the logos came into the world
and he's going to give gift after gift
wow he has eternal life if you eat his
flesh and drink his blood you have life
in you Jesus's first miracle is at a
wedding
supplying wine to people who were
already drunk
now come on this is all dionysian and it
was recognized to be so in Antiquity we
have we have commentators that talk
about Jesus and and Dionysus in that way
so it's really quite obvious yeah so the
Gospel of John represents the end of the
canonical gospel sequence and it itself
has these three stages that are
discernible and by the way they're not
discernible on ideology alone they're
also uh discernible in terms of language
oh really and and structure and so on
wow so when you say a language are you
talking about like the like for example
John 1 1 with what he's saying and how
you know some people say it's inspired
by Philo you know
I don't think it is I think it's
inspired by the opening monologue uh in
euripides Buckeye where
um a Dionysus disguised as a priest
comes forward and says I the son of Zeus
have come to Thebes to punish it for
having not accepted that I am in fact
the son of Zeus and I need to honor my
mother in doing it and I'm especially
going to kick butt with
um pantheus the king well what happens
in the Gospel of John
Jesus is the law of us who comes from
God yeah in him was life
not punishment dependious not to the
world he comes in the world the world
did not accept him yeah but to those who
accept him he gives eternal life he's
giving gift after gift and so Jesus is
the donor deity that you have in the
Greek world with Dionysus and Demeter
wow wow another another very clear
parallel so it should be but other
people uh seldom have seen it yeah wow
wow and we're definitely going to touch
on that I have so many questions I hope
I have time to get through all them I'm
gonna have to skip some here
unfortunately so did the people at the
time of Jesus recognize these parallels
some of them did yeah but it's a good
question and now there seems to be a
growing
position
that
both the authors and their first readers
were more sophisticated than we thought
wow and they weren't necessarily written
to be read in communities in worship
that they may have been written to other
intellectuals to
um almost as a game to to play with
Nemesis is it so I but some did
understand it in fact surely Luke
understood what was going on in Mark
yeah
um and so but you have other examples of
knowledge too now in the Byzantine
Christians we know
saw these similarities because they
retold gospel stories Yeah by using the
same homeric lines had inspired them and
most of that has not been translated
into English but I do so uh from for the
reader in this book I see perfect
perfect so again again just a great
resource to be able to you know look at
these parallels without having to search
through the internet and you know a risk
maybe it wasn't it hasn't not been
translated or maybe not translated
accurately to really you know recognize
these so that's a great answer let's go
to
um a very
um
interesting question I'd say
why haven't New Testament Scholars like
Bart Ehrman recognize these parallels
one time I told Bart German he'd have to
rewrite his introduction to the New
Testament if I'm right oh yeah and uh he
he shut me down really oh yeah he
doesn't have any he's tone deaf to uh to
classical poetry uh and I like the guy
yeah more or less yeah but you know I'm
disappointed his work has not extended
in this direction I think uh Rami the
reasons are pretty simple
um the history of New Testament
scholarship has built up an enormous
library of commentary
mostly in the west yeah where people are
no longer familiar with ancient Greek
yeah um you know Homer and so on
and in fact in the West Homer was lost
for centuries so that it was only in the
East where you had preservation of the
America epic Sensei and some of
um in the Greek poetry so it was lost in
the history of scholarship
um another is that or Christians were
understandably more interested in Jewish
parallels in large measure because the
New Testament is a sequel to the Old
Testament yeah in the so-called Old
Testament with the Hebrew Bible yeah um
because they get bound together in the
fourth Century I see so that seems to be
the more natural cultural uh context
yeah but actually for the gospel authors
it was the Greek World let me give you
an example yeah
um we have catalogs of Greek fragments
of literary papyri that go from the 200
BC to 200 A.D yeah we have five
fragments of the Jewish Bible in Greek
okay we have over 600 of Homer wow now
what books do you think people had
access to
um in at the time of the writing of the
New Testament
they had they were much more familiar
with Homer the Septuagint the Greek
Bible was never used for Education until
the 5th Century yeah in the East it was
if if you knew Greek you'd gone to
school and you'd studied Homer and
students hated it because the whole
Merit Greek's difficult and it's not the
language that they spoke at home wow wow
so it was almost like a standard
um part of the curriculum for a lot of
you know it was the curriculum wow wow
and almost from the beginning one of the
first uh exercises in one grammarian is
to write out in Greek the Homer was not
a man but a god wow well that that gets
you going
absolutely absolutely I think there's
even a parallel there you know between
uh between him and Jesus and that in
that case then you know the idea of
yeah I guess so yeah yeah and that's
actually a question that's sorry I guess
a reduced version of the the greater
question that I'm definitely going to
get to later so the New Testament Jesus
actually this is the question right here
the New Testament Jesus is described as
the Divine Son of God who was killed and
resurrected is this concept original or
has it appeared before
we have lots of dying and Rising deities
in antiquity
um I'm not an authority on that so much
so
um but I surely there are analogies out
there and I know that people have
um have talked about them what we can
say is that the idea of Resurrection in
empty tombs
was so widespread well let me give
another example
the Roman emperors were considered to be
divine wow and sometimes they after
their death they were thought to have
ascended into the sky and become gods
they were coins minted in for them wow
so we know that of the Roman emperors
now how far we can take that back to uh
the Greek world I'm not sure wow okay
all right great answer thank you very
much so this um it's kind of a offshoe
of a it's a similar question to what I
just asked
um in John 6 verse 53-55 Jesus allegedly
says truly I say to you unless you eat
the Flesh of son of man and drink his
blood you have no life in you is this
concept of you know eating the Flesh of
God or you know the Son of God something
that is original to Jesus or has that
appeared in history comes right out of
dionysian religion really yeah it's
called the omaphagia the eating of raw
flesh yeah and this margig Moss the um
the rending up of a ritual animal
and it's related to Dionysus having died
in Ben and restored to life
um
by Zeus
um and I had a student do a dissertation
on this and it's it's clear that it's a
dionysian illusion yeah and it's not the
Last Supper as it is in the Gospels it
appears earlier in the gospels and it's
a it's a nod to dionysian religion that
Jesus can give life to
wow okay very interesting so it's a very
clearly another form of literary either
literary Nemesis or just kind of
alluding to no it's not Nemesis honestly
Rami in this case it's going to be more
of history of religions yeah that um
religions have discourse with them each
other as we are yeah and um they borrow
from each other and they compete with
each other this is I think a competition
not at the point of
the literature but in terms of the
history of religions I see okay thank
you for clearing that up so we just to
clear what we've established with the
gospels and in some parts of the New
Testament
um they were written by very learned
Greek authors who use litter literary
Nemesis uh to really
exacerbate how amazing Jesus was and by
using these stories from the past
putting them onto Jesus and making him
better that you know then maybe then he
actually was or maybe he was that great
I don't know but these details were kind
of added by yeah I wouldn't say the
gospel authors especially at Mark and
Matthew were first class intellectuals
yeah but I think
um the author of Luke X really was quite
brilliant really familiar with Greek
philosophy and and in The Iliad some of
his invitations usually are absolutely
spectacular yeah and we haven't talked
about those but I'm not sure we need to
yeah so I wouldn't say that they are
um the first rung of uh intellectuals
yeah
um although Luke might be there yeah
um but they're they certainly are
educated yeah they know how to handle a
nemesis in Greek poetry absolutely all
right perfect so now I now that we've
established that about the authors and
the gospels and literary Nemesis used in
the gospels I want to take a step back
because
um many
conclude that the gospel authors were
following Paul's christology and were
greatly influenced by Paul so it almost
seems to be the case that if they were
not eyewitnesses and they're going based
off of Paul's christology then a lot of
it really falls back on what Paul
believed and wrote and kind of
speculated would you agree with that or
would you say that that is not exactly
the case
um well in favor of that position would
be that the Apostle Paul is the hero of
the Acts of the Apostles and Luke writes
his gospel in anticipation of the acts
and it would be astonishing that he was
not at least to some extent informed by
Pauline Epistles and Pauline theology
yeah but I think that's about as far as
it goes I do not buy that the gospel of
Mark is heavily influenced by Paul but I
do think there are fascinating parallels
to First Corinthians one of the books
yeah and so but I don't think it goes
very far in explaining the gospels for
example Matthew doesn't seem to be
interested in Paul at all the gospel
John doesn't seem to be interested in
Paul at all yeah and we haven't talked
about papius of harryopolis who wrote
before Luke and John and he's writing
from Western Asia Minor hereopolis is
near colossian laodicea and he doesn't
have any impulse to
um to pay tribute to Paul there's
nothing Pauline in what we have of the
expositions by papias so I think it's a
it's a legitimate intellectual question
yeah but I think
um
it may be a fishing Expedition that
doesn't give you sailfish but minnows
all right all right very fair very fair
so
is it is it possible that
they shared the beliefs of Paul and did
not pay tribute to him in the gospels or
would you say that would be uncommon for
them too no it's possible yeah okay all
right so
this moving on to and this actually has
to do with Luke who you mentioned wrote
Acts of the Apostles is there any
literary Nemesis in the conversion of
Saul of Tarsus de Paul of Tarsus because
I've heard that allegedly it resembles a
character named pantheist
um in a play written by euripides maybe
400 years before Jesus perfect yes
indeed this is the same play that I said
influenced the Gospel of John wow right
euripides Baka yeah pantheist is the bad
boy
and in fact in the Acts of the Apostles
um we have a quotation where Dionysus in
Disguise Warren spenthius
um I would not fight against a God yeah
it's hard to kick against the goad yeah
and that's right out of the Buckeye I
mean it's a little differently phrased
but that's what it is and so the story
is that Dionysus is in Disguise enthus
denies his divinity
and um and he's upset about the women of
Thebes going out into the mountains and
in Crazy worship yeah
yeah and um Dionysus
warns pantheists that you ought not to
to mess with me basically and in the end
of the play he dies so what's different
is that Paul
sees the light if you will yeah that
when pentheist did not and by the way
here's another piece of that yeah yeah
the one who sees most clearly in the
bakai is a blind man
it's teresus and what happens to Paul
after he his his conversion or it's his
calling I guess it's conversion in Acts
I would say yeah
um he's blinded it temporarily so you
have the theme of blindness in them wow
and then there's another character that
is named elemis whose name means well I
don't want to go into it but there's
another character who also plays the
role of penteus wow wow okay that's um
that's tremendous so we have Luke uh
writing an acts about his I believe his
teacher Paul and his conversion Story
and Another clear form of I'd say maybe
even one of the most clear forms of
literary Nemesis yeah let me go a little
further about Paul yeah please
Paul does not say that that experience
he had of the Risen Christ
was a conversion oh really no it's a
calling to open up the promises of
Israel to gentiles
it's an expansion of his mission it's
it's it was a change of position because
instead of persecuting the followers of
Jesus he now wanted to include them in
the fortunes of Israel the prophetic
fortunes of Israel I see so it's Luke
who comes wrong and makes it a
conversion to a different religion
because of the Buckeye wow wow I see
that's very interesting how you know how
maybe the christology and these certain
you know characters
I'd say maybe transform over over the
years even the idea of Jesus you know
from how you described him in the gospel
of Q which I will get to
um to you know how you know the the
later evangelists view him and how Paul
views him as this God now you can really
see some kind of transformation there so
I think that's very interesting so a few
more maybe hopefully quick fire
questions um I know I'm asking some very
loaded questions so hopefully this these
will be a little
um a little quicker did Paul ever meet
Jesus no
other than his uh what Luke claims was
division there's no actual meeting well
no Paul claims to have seen the Risen
Christ yeah yeah okay all right so did
Paul witness the crucifixion at least no
okay
um Paul was from Tarsus you know given
the name Saul of Tarsus
um which is the center of Greek
philosophy was Paul influenced by
Hellenistic philosophy in any way oh he
had to have been but of course he calls
himself a Pharisee yeah so
um but there have been some wonderful
studies that compare Paul to
um
a cynic philosophy yeah and to some
extent stoicism or middle platonism so
um yes look intellectual was living at
that time in the world are going to be
influenced by philosophical uh Trends
yeah 100 so
um and that was actually my next
question
um you know he actually quotes one of
the hymns to Zeus uh when it says
something along the lines of we are thy
children Offspring and he writes I'm
assuming to the Gentiles you know it's
even written in your poems we are thy
Offspring but it's really strange
because do Christians believe in Zeus
because he that's what he was quoting so
it seems very clearly that he was
influenced and maybe even used it in his
remember that's not coming from Paul
that's coming from The Acts of the
Apostles that puts that in Paul's mouth
so it's Luke saying to on Paul's
Authority and in that sermon where he
gives where's he give it he gives it in
Athens he talks about
um you know the Superstition and so on
he he talks about God he never mentions
Jesus as
um the role of the revealer or salvation
or whatever
so this is another example of
um Luke creating Paul to be a Socrates
character wow in Athens talking about
the uh the problem of superstition and
giving an understanding of God that is
different wow all right that's amazing
so you had mentioned that many you know
maybe believe that Paul was a cynic
philosopher in in some sense Burton Mack
has said this as well
um would you agree that he was some kind
of cynic philosopher
um no I don't think he was a cynic
philosopher but I think that a certain
amount of cynicism was uh present yes
especially you can see it in Lucy in the
samosara
um in his satires
um many of his philosophers are
um cynics precisely because they
represent a critique of the wealth of
the Roman Empire
and so menipus goes to the netherworld
and it sees the punishments of the rich
hey in the acts of the in Luke's gospel
yeah
there's a poor man named Lazarus who
goes to Abraham's bosom and there's a
rich man who goes to Hades and he can't
get out of there it's coming right out
of Odyssey book 11. wow where Odysseus
goes and he sees Tantalus and tantled
where we get the word tantalizing
Tantalus cannot be get Satisfaction by
having water or fruit all right so so
there was a level of
um you know I say persuasion or
influence on philosophy on what you know
Paul believed yes and I I think that
it's fair enough to say that there are
cynic impulses in much of the philosophy
so Paul working for himself
um the value of sacrifice
sure did Paul believe in the Trinity and
the way that Christians you know let's
say Catholics do today or the Council of
nicaea did maybe in the year 400 no no
so
and and the reason I asked that is
because he says something very
particular
um in First Corinthians 11 he says but I
wanted to realize that the head of every
man is Christ the head of every woman is
man and the head of Christ is God so is
this some kind of indicator that he was
a subordinationist that he believed
Jesus was subordinate to the father
if there's one passage of the New
Testament I'm most embarrassed by it's
that really
because it indicates that women are
inferior to men yeah and they're not in
the Divine image in the same way they're
vulnerable to Angels who are going to
lust after them so they have to wear
veils on their heads and
um so as God is the head of Christ and a
man and Christ is the head of a man
what kind of anthropology is that yeah
yeah what kind of theology is that
that's embarrassing and then it's been
used so often to keep women in
subordinate positions yeah that's a
great that's actually a really good
point because um it's it's it's you know
someone could argue that okay a man's
ahead of the household but it's really
it's different when you say that a man
is the head of the woman the same way
Jesus is the head you know God is the
head of a man that kind of God Christ
man woman yeah well you know what kind
of uh anthropology is that yeah yeah
that's a great Point actually I never
thought of that I was so focused on I
was so focused on Trinity yeah you know
the Muslim issue yeah 100 absolutely
it's uh definitely my bias there but
that's a really good observation who
told Paul Jesus was crucified if he
didn't witness it
oh I think that that
um was a historical fact yeah and it's
what generates the gospels to some
extent they're trying to figure out
since we have this teacher
who was preaching the kingdom of God
and created crowds about him who were in
enjoying a different kind of Judaism
from the Judaism in Galilee yeah and
then the authorities in Jerusalem
probably of Jews but also of course
Romans
executed him what does that mean for
this proclamation of the kingdom of God
and it was that cognitive dissonance
that emerges in myth where Jesus is
raised from the dead I see so
um this the fact that Jesus was killed
is the one historical fact we know about
Jesus that Paul knew and I think it
would have been ubiquitous yeah
what does ubiquitous mean I mean
everywhere yeah yeah okay so everyone
was saying that yeah and it and it and
it happened yeah so if he knows anything
about Jesus he's going to be he's the
crucified one yeah yeah and I'm really
glad I'm almost glad that you hold this
position because
um I do want to talk about it because as
you probably know in the Quran in Islam
we don't believe Jesus was even
crucified to begin with and the passage
that you know it doesn't just say that
it specifies why people believe that he
was so hopefully we will get to that and
I hope we get to a point in the
discussion where you can openly ask any
questions about Islam and we can have
you know that discussion from a
theological and you know scholar uh
scholarly and historical standpoint so
I'm very excited for that I wanna I
wanna ask you about Galatians one
because I think it's very interesting
um what uh just to make sure Paul wrote
Galatians yeah okay perfect so I don't
want to make the same mistake I made
last time so
Paul opens Galatians basically you know
after opening it he mentions Jesus gave
himself for Humanity and then he jumps
to the astonishment that people are
turning to a different gospel uh he says
that people are trying to confuse others
about the true gospel of Christ he says
that even if an angel from heaven were
to preach a different gospel don't take
anything that basically opposes his
gospel then he says he does not want to
please people so perhaps this indicates
that people were displeased with him at
the time and calling him maybe a you
know heretical in some fashion and then
he says that and this is very
interesting
that this gospel is not from human
origin he did not get it from any man
but direct Revelation from Jesus himself
then he tells a story and feels the need
to clarify I'm not lying guys I promise
so it almost seems that when you read
this you know me as a Layman when I read
it in a very skeptical manner people
were displeased with Paul believed in a
different gospel to what he believed
were very upset that he's saying what
he's saying about Jesus and that they
maybe even called him a liar to some
extent and he needed to clarify I'm not
lying you know and also I think the the
major Point
um that I want to ask about is he seemed
to
um not have gotten what he believed
about Jesus or A lot of it from people
because he says this is a revelation
from God so did he not speak to James
and Peter and the people who witnessed
Jesus no he did yeah but he's not
claiming that that's where he derived
his gospel yeah now
um to answer this question it would take
a longer time than we have yeah
one of my methodologies that I'm really
invested in and it appears in the
synopsis book yeah
is what I call social identity criticism
yeah social identity criticism is not
interested in theology or religion as
such yeah it's interested in Social
organization how is it that people
organize themselves into voluntary
associations and what is the dynamic of
that and the dynamic is basic and by the
way you have this as a great explanation
of Islam and its varieties yeah so that
um you identify yourself with Islam and
probably with a certain kind of Islam
yeah and so that is what takes your
energy now when you have a definition of
your sect of Islam you also know who you
are not yes so you have out groups
different forms of Muslim different
kinds Christians and Jews and uh
atheists like myself and so on so um but
in order to understand
your in-group you often have an ideal a
prototypical leader a leader often a
historical character who gives you the
authority and the wisdom for your group
to live by its own wisdom yeah and so
you have these three aspects of social
identity and this is a form of
sociological analysis which I call
social identity criticism because I
think it actually is a hermeneutic so
one is you have ideal leaders often as
teachers or intellectuals that have a
following around them with the generally
a very simple message but it has then
profound implications for other things
yeah people galvanize and associate with
them and have certain Norms of behavior
that are then
dictated by the ethos of this group yeah
and then you're willing to say you are
not somebody else now sometimes that
you're not someone else leads to Warfare
yeah or argumentation and we don't want
to go there yeah but it's all of us are
involved in voluntary associations where
we have leaders that that represent our
ideals and we have identification over
against someone else and the reason we
do it is the world is messy and chaotic
and we need to have a home
yeah intellectually right
now what's going on in Galatians is Paul
only somehow gets himself on the outside
of the galatian church at least some of
them
so they have a different
um presumably a different ideal leader
and these are the super Apostles yeah
that he talks about and so Paul is on
the outside of a group that he founded
so then you have these rival in groups
and the in-groups are considering Paul
to be an outsider and he's using the
rhetoric of divine revelation even if an
angel gives it you you're this stuff I
get it directly from God so forget the
angels and stuff yeah
um and what and then he goes into this
polemic about what the in-group should
represent what the out group should
represent and so on so it's a beautiful
example of how social identity functions
in making
theological claims yeah now
unfortunately because Galatians is in
the New Testament and the intent the New
Testament for many people is the
Christian word of God God yeah
um his word has to be taken as the final
uh The Final Answer yeah but I don't
think it needs to be the final answer I
think we can read Galatians
dialectically that is to see how the
conversation works and what's at stake
in one in-group battling another
in-group valorizing a different source
of authority and then sometimes defining
the leader as an out group member yeah
that's that's very interesting because
um I believe the Quran actually
asserts that in a way
um with a very simple line which I will
get to towards the end I have a full
list of things that I want to discuss
with you in regards to that so that is
very interesting
so how many groups were there would you
say and do you know do we know what
their different beliefs were and let me
preface by saying all over you know
Paul's writing there's a huge emphasis
and I would say also in in the gospels
as you know you go from Mark to Matthew
to Luke to John there is so much
emphasis put on the crucifixion and the
cross and you know what it what it
represents so much so that you know by
the time you get to the gospel of Peter
which was not you know included in the
New Testament because they rejected it
you have a talking cross coming out of
the Tomb you know and um some people
what I've heard said is that to really
drive a point home like Jesus was
crucified for you know Salvation of
humanity and the Believers you have to
really exacerbate the details around it
so that's why we go from the curtain
tearing in the temple and darkness to
those two and uh some kind of like
zombie apocalypse where all the saints
were risen you know adding that detail
really I'd say brings the point Homer
shows it off a lot more so my question
is
um is it possible that people disagreed
with Paul on Jesus being crucified since
he pushes it so much that I teach you
nothing but Jesus and him crucified you
know who has Bewitched you basically
like to go against the cross or is this
alluding to something else a different
disagreement
well I don't think we have enough
information to know if people disagreed
with
um Jesus on the cross we certainly know
that they differed about what that meant
um so I think I just I'd leave it there
probably now let's go back to the
beginning yeah
um the job of Theology and to some
extent inter-religious discourse
is a way of trying to systematize either
your own scriptures or the scriptures of
another
that in my view borders on idolatry
because it
um it does not take into account
diversity
so for example we miss the voices of
women in the early Christian texts yeah
we miss the voices of slaves
we miss the voices of Africans yeah so
um we are
we just don't know as much as we'd want
to and by then trying to harmonize
everything in the New Testament into a
theological system is in my view a
problem yeah
um I'd like to put it this way if you
insist on homogenized milk
you'll never have cheese or cream or
butter yeah right so it's much better to
look at these things sociologically and
see the energy that it takes for these
groups to talk to each other yeah now um
as an outsider I I fear that certain
kinds of
um theologizing in Islam do the same
thing yeah instead of valorizing the
diverse Rich diversity of what it means
to be Muslim yeah in Muslim history it
it becomes then dogmatic
and it becomes you know homogenizing and
I think Islam is a lot better as butter
milk and cheese than it is uh
homogenized milk okay so could you give
me an example of you know how you think
Islam kind of portrays this well I think
Islam is
um better off in trying to make that
claim because you basically have only
one human revealer yeah okay so you can
say that because you have one human
revealer that it also should make a
sense it should be coherent yeah well
some Scholars are saying that in fact
the Quran was the result of a process of
of patching together too so you you know
that's a different story yeah
um but I think there is a danger in all
religions of
absolutizing their own position we
certainly have it in the history of
Christianity
and I I suspect we have it in Islam yeah
to absolutize your own position and then
to say that we have the truth and you
don't yeah I just don't think that's the
way to get around especially in the
modern world yeah yeah 100 and it's not
100 does have that position actually it
specifically says about Jesus which I
will get to they did not kill him they
did not crucify him um and those who
differ in this don't have any knowledge
you know that basically we are revealing
the truth about Jesus and obviously the
position comes from and there's true
perspective there's the religious you
know um
um theological perspective and then the
more so naturalistic
um you know a religious perspective
which um with for academics they need
you know they have to take this approach
because no one's going to believe you if
you say no well God says in the Quran
that this happened to Jesus so therefore
that happened historically no that's not
valid because um that does not count as
empirical evidence but for a religious
person if you have a person who is
convinced that you know Islam is the
truth one is the word of God then the
word of God would triumph over you know
everything else so on a personal level
and I think even someone on an academic
level depending on what you're talking
about the Quran will have
um you know Authority or some kind of
say or some kind of you know
um authenticity but on a purely academic
and scholarly level no one's going to
appeal to that because you just cannot
really prove in a naturalistic sense
that you know this should be taken as an
authority okay yeah so let's jump to the
gospel of Q very quickly the gospel of Q
is said to be written earlier than all
the other gospels and is said to be a
basically a source that Matthew and Luke
used I know that you mentioned Q you
have your own hypothesis in in your book
about Q Q Plus and they call it the Q
Plus pantheist hypothesis I believe
right yes so could you tell us a little
bit about that and do you believe the
gospel of Q actually existed yes I do
I'm in fact I'm doing a book now that is
called humor and the quests for Q and
Jesus yeah and it's coming out it's a
companion to the synopsis book and it's
an argument for cue that's very
different from standard cues yeah and I
really don't think we have time to go
into the differences between my IQ and
other cues but I use different criteria
to evaluate Q I think Mark Nuku and in
fact Mark in some ways is the most
important witness to Q so that is
different from other Q reconstructions
yeah
um I also think that Luke knew Matthew
and therefore you have to have different
criteria for teasing Q out of the
document for me social identity theory
is very important because you can see
there are no Greek mythological Echoes
In The Q document they're coming from
Judaism the bad boys the out group is a
tour enforce officers that is Pharisees
it's not Chief priests it's not Romans
it's the dispute is about Jewish law
Jesus is the more compassionate Moses
and so on and I think it's the most
important document we have about the
historical Jesus I wouldn't say that
there's anything that I can be sure that
Jesus said in the Q document yeah but I
think we surely can say that the authors
Viewpoint about Jesus and posturing him
inside of Judaism is Right On Target for
him and for his audience and it has
similarities in Philo and in Paul wow so
that this is a very important witness to
the historical Jesus again not because
we can hear Jesus's words
but we can hear his theological voice
yeah if you will how is he posturing
himself inside of Israel yeah all right
so very beautifully said and I'm glad
you mentioned the point that it really
is a kind of a testament to who Jesus
was historically and what his message
was
um the gospel of Q does it have any
passion narrative in it no none at all
in fact it's written by a Jew it's not
written by a Christian at all wow it
knows of Jesus's crucifixion yeah but
it's the crucifixion of a martyr and God
will let Jesus come back and punish his
enemies and redeem the righteous that's
the author's understanding of the future
yeah but it's there's no salvation by
faith in Jesus there's no Resurrection
it's an exaltation of Jesus and
Vindication by God who will send him
back as the Glorious son of man but it's
not written by Christians written by a
Jew wow and and this Jew believed in
Jesus as a prophet Messiah and did
believe Jesus would come back for a
second coming yes wow that's tremendous
Jesus Barabbas and the whole
you know Pontius Pilates pascals pardon
you know it's a lot of Peace there but
you know the Pascal's part in that
pilate hide Jesus of Nazareth
um you know and then Jesus Brabus and
Barabbas means son of the father right
so you have Jesus you know son of man
and in a way son of the father and they
have Jesus Brabus who son of the father
Jesus Brabus was a kind of political
reformer he was a freedom fighter for
the Jews he was trying to fight for
Jewish freedom and basically kind of
revolt against the Roman Empire at the
time and I believe um Josephus and Philo
they describe pilate as being inflexible
very kind of dominant he was willing to
really
um murder an entire group of of
innocently protesting Jews
just for innocently protesting do you
think it's historically plausible that
he would give such a pardon especially
given the risk that you know such a
reformer and murderer like Jesus Brabus
would be on the loose again but I don't
think there was a whereabas at all at
all wow so you think he was invented
invented and I think I know what
character The Invention was it's a rogue
in Odyssey 17 named Iris yeah and it's a
nickname it's what he was called his um
his birth name was Arness
the same thing's true of Barabbas it's
that's what he was called it's a
nickname for him now what is the
nickname it's son of the father yeah now
you have two sons of the father you've
got one who's the son of God according
to the author of Mark and you have
another one's called son of the father
now one is a preacher of light and love
yeah and the other is a revolutionary
now if you were a pilot who would you
want to to let off you'd want to let
Jesus off yeah Jesus of Nazareth but who
is it that Shin shouts out you know
crucify him crucify him giving Barabbas
it's the chief priests who rip up the
crowd
so it's an anti-jewishop polemic yeah it
is created to
um
to punish Jews and to make them
responsible for the death of Jesus so
even Joe even though Jesus was punished
with the crucifixion which is of course
a Roman form of execution pilate didn't
want to do it he was they the Jews
forced his hand yeah so it's a very
despicable piece of
um manipulation and in most cases I like
what Mark does but in this case I think
it's really despicable yeah 100 so
um how about on the note of like Simon
of Cyrene you know I mentioned him
earlier to you before the recording and
like Judas iscaria Judas Iscariot
apparently the literal meaning of that
is a Jew from the city no it does not it
does not mean that it means into the
city yeah and it it there's a homeric
equivalent in melanthius who is the the
uh the great villain of the Odyssey
one of Odysseus's slaves who then turns
on him insides with the suitors and
actually arms them and tries to uh to
kill Odysseus wow and when you first see
him in the Odyssey he's going into the
city
so this is a beautiful word play East in
Greek means into yeah and kiriot that's
right it does mean into a city or a
village yeah
um but it's um it's a unusual compound
now you mentioned Simon of cyreni yeah
what is Peter's
is there a Simon Peter yes Peter's name
was did Simon Peter hear Jesus say you
should bury your own cross yeah did
Simon Peter said if I die with you I'll
not deny you so is it Simon Peter who
carries Jesus's cross
or is it Simon of cyrenees
cyrini is in Northern Africa yeah so
he's not even a Palestinian yeah and
he's got two boys one is Alexandria the
other is Rufus they're obviously
hellenized one has a Greek name the
other is Latin name yeah for pity sake
to say that Simon Peter blew it wow and
that those who are going to
um
to be rewarded by God are going to be
those who do the will of God so it's not
Joseph of Nazareth who buries his son
yeah it's Joseph of Arimathea excellent
discipleship he's not Mary of Nazareth
who is there to anoint her son yeah it's
Mary Magdalene and another Mary so these
names are significant names Rami and
they help one understand the the
Glorious sophistication of Mark even
though in many cases I would say that um
I'd have to disagree with him yeah yeah
all right that's that's that's
incredible I think there's a lot of
people you know watching this video in
the audience thinking Judas didn't was
he real he didn't exist to you is he an
anti-jewish Trope what about Simon
didn't exist the whole story of Simons
of cyreni carrying the cross for Jesus
didn't exist what about you know I
mentioned this before apparently uh
Church Father bacilities believed that
Simon was crucified instead of Jesus but
he never existed you know it's it's it's
it's insane how you know deep this this
history goes so I know you have to get
going I do quickly because I didn't say
I will want I do want to talk about
Islam just a little bit if you have any
questions please you know feel free to
ask so
I believe that our christology of Jesus
lines up more with the historical Jesus
uh you know the Q document and maybe
even the Nazarene Jews who believed
Jesus not the ones that rejected he was
the Messiah
um the reason for that is because of the
following passages in the Quran so all
throughout the Quran it affirms that
Jesus was the prophet the messenger and
the Messiah specifically in chapter 19
verse 37 it mentions and this is the
verse I was talking about before in
terms of your Social uh Theory but the
different groups uh kind of differed
amongst themselves in regards to Jesus
so basically says what the Quran says
happened with Jesus who he was and then
it says afterwards you know there was
there was a disagreement there was
fighting and you know inner fighting
with these different groups about who
Jesus was did he really die was he the
Messiah was he crucified is he the Son
of God and so on and so forth next it
mentions 279 and I think that's very
interesting so woe to those who write
the scripture with their own hands and
say this is from God you know they only
seek a fleeting gain you know in this
world so some believe that you know
maybe Paul was a an amateur philosopher
who just wanted to you know kind of make
it up in the ranks and I'd say he did
that you know while we were talking
about him now 2000 years later
um and it's interesting the Quran
mentioned scripture particularly you
know the gospels and so on and so forth
and people writing with their own hands
saying this is from God you know the
belief about the New Testament is that
it's the inspired word of God and when
they have all these you know literary uh
Nemesis as you mentioned
and chapter 3 verse 50
um and this I think you're really gonna
enjoy it says that Jesus said to his
disciples and the people I will confirm
the Torah revealed before me and make
lawful some of that which had been made
unlawful to you so you have Jesus coming
and saying to the people some of the
things that were made you know unlawful
for you prohibited for you I'm actually
gonna basically present a a more
compassionate version of the law
something that is easier uh to practice
than what you had had uh before
and the Quran this is the big one right
unequivocally denies oh no this is not a
big one Anna quickly denies Jesus being
God and so on and so forth by making
very simple um case that Jesus just like
his mom ate food you know so how is that
God you know need sustenance in food and
so on and so forth this is more of a
philosophical argument does not make
sense now what I think is astonishing
about this is this was recited all by
like you mentioned one man the prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him to the people
of Arabia 1400 years ago before the
Bible was even translated into Arabic
now you did have people who spoke
different languages and could have you
know talked about it
um but to mention very specific things
uh like the possibility of them making
it up because they at the time believe
that this is historically accurate
um the idea that Jesus came to you know
as a you know kind of Jewish reformer in
a way I want to make the law easier for
you
um I think is is tremendous because it's
very specific you know out of all things
you could have claimed you could have
you know you claimed that and I know I'm
going on a lot but now this is the big
kicker
the Jews did not believe that Jesus was
the Messiah
and they believed he was crucified which
is why in their estimation he's not not
the Messiah and then the Christians
believed that he was crucified and he
was the Messiah and the Quran does
something that is a pretty tremendous
for the time it disagrees with both of
them you know uh the prophet Muhammad
could not read or write he wasn't really
you know taught these things educating
these things and he's coming and saying
basically you're both wrong
um he was in the Quran says
um that the Jews at the time you know
they mockingly boasted we killed the
Messiah Jesus Son of Mary messenger of
God but they neither killed him nor
crucified him but it only appeared so
um and those who differ are full of
doubts and they have no certain
knowledge they follow nothing but
conjecture they certainly did not uh
kill him and then God says that he
raised them up to himself like as is
mentioned in psalm 91. so it was a
pretty outrageous claim to make at the
time but now when we're you know using
uh you know modern day scholarship
um and Academia we see how much
conjecture there really is around Jesus
if people who wrote the gospels use
literary nemesis
um and these stories are not true and
the gospel of Q doesn't mention anything
in the passion narrative
um and you say it does hit to the the
crucifixion was actually the first time
I'm hearing that so I'm interested in
that
um but you know it does not mention
these these things that Christians hold
you know so dear to heart as almost a
fact today so I know I said a lot about
I I want to know if you have any
questions about the Quran or about Islam
um
I can only say at places where I would
differ yeah
um in a friendly way of course so this
is not a a slam on Islam it's Islam on
it's coming from my own understanding
yeah first of all
Jews themselves recognize the Mosaic law
was oppressive and so the mishnah in the
talmud are ways of saying how can we be
faithful to law
but make it manageable
and a lot of sharia law is similar to
that how can we valorize our commitments
and what we think God wants but make it
work for people in more compassionate
ways and in the history of sharia law
you have new challenges that have to do
with the place of women in society for
example or multiculturalism yeah and so
on
I think
what I would say is that Judaism Islam
and the the Christian tradition
find different ways to adapt the
diversity of early Christian texts about
who Jesus was yeah
to serve other kinds of purposes that is
to
claim him as one of the prototypical
leaders who can supply wisdom and models
for the in-group
for some it's the the crucifixion of
Jesus is the atoning act of God on
behalf of humankind so that
um God kills his own son in order to
give us eternal life I mean how barbaric
is that right
others would say that the death of Jesus
was the court was the result of his
trying to transform Jewish law yeah
because it caused disturbances in the
Jewish community that the Romans
couldn't tolerate yeah it also is clear
from the Q document that even though
people assumed that Jesus died that's
not what was important about him yeah it
was important about his wisdom and his
teaching of the kingdom of God you see
this in the Gospel of Thomas where
there's no reference at all to narrative
about Jesus it's all the secret
teachings that went to Thomas yeah
so this is another example I think that
inter-religious dialogue needs to be
candid you need to own the Islam that
you value so much yeah and we have to
hear each other
but there's one other thing I want to
say Rami yeah I'm uh I'm a Christian
identified non-believer yeah
and
um I like to think of myself as a
humanist scholar who's trying to be
even-handed with these texts and to
discover things that we haven't seen
before yeah
um but you have Islamic scholars too who
are doing the same kind of work who may
not be as
faithful as you are or as as other as
imams might be but
um nonetheless they're devoted to the
tradition and they're looking for
insight yeah so I hope this conversation
that we're hope having opens up a way of
viewing more critically ourselves as
well as the other yeah absolutely 100
and I think that's a very beautiful note
to end it on thank you so much Dr
McDonald for joining me today again we
are
very proud to announce and mention the
synopsis of Epic tragedy and the Gospels
it really is a beautiful point of
reference for people looking to get
looking to get into you know New
Testament studies and all that
especially Layman like myself but before
we go I actually do have a small gift
for you
um I wanted to give you the Quran and
this little paper here is every mention
of Jesus in the Quran
of course it's my pleasure and with that
being said
and I agree with that
hope you guys enjoyed that interview
just as much as I did unfortunately we
did have to end it right then due to
time constraints but there were some
things I wanted to talk about from an
Islamic perspective that we just did not
have time to talk about during the
actual interview so first is uh the idea
of the Sharia changing this is something
Dr McDonald mentioned uh that some imams
are trying to change the studio to make
it more compassionate however from an
Islamic perspective obviously Muslims
who believe in God believe that the law
of god is perfect because God is
all-knowing and all wise and anything he
decides is always in the best interest
of man and the society as a whole I
think the main issue actually comes into
play when human beings who are
subjective and yes have their own
desires biases and wants but don't know
what is actually best for us come into
play and this is something I can
demonstrate with liberalism itself I
mean if you think about the last 300
years of liberalism and how much it's
changed we think we're amazing now let's
you know fast forward 50 years into the
future how different of a society will
we have culturally so actually morally
and legislatively
as for Islam when you look 1400 years
ago one of the things Dr McDonald
mentioned was women's place in society
if you go back just a few hundred years
in the west women could not work they
could not get an education they could
not vote they could not own property
they basically were property in a sense
and this was kind of similar to how
pre-islamic Arabia was but once Islam
came women were not property they had
the right to own property women could
vote women could get an education women
could teach women could own businesses
and so on and so forth and women were
not inherited as property
in a way you might see in different kind
of cultures and laws similarly you find
that the West has a huge intolerance
towards other people's cultures that's
why they invaded certain places like in
the Middle East and other parts of the
world in the name of liberating them
it was basically masking their
intolerance of their way of life and
trying to force another way of life or
their own way of life onto different
people who frankly did not want to
accept it so although it is true that
the Sharia will have some components of
it that will change the ruling based on
the situation and that is allowed within
the confines of Islam it is not
necessarily true that human beings can
change the law of God just because they
feel it's not compassionate enough
because there's no such thing as full
compassion because you can't be
compassionate with you know Killers or
murderers in a holistic sense maybe you
can reduce their sentence or give them a
lighter sentence but if anything that
would just
push them to want to do the crime a
little bit more or at least it will not
prevent it as much as it could secondly
I want to mention that in the Quran
Allah says they did not kill him they
did not crucify him but it was made to
appear that way so when we look at the
historicity of Jesus and of early
Christianity in the multitude of views
that were held amongst them was the view
that Jesus was not crucified as I
believe early second century a Church
Father bacilities believed in but you
had the mainstream view which is like
Jesus was crucified now this actually
does not really go against Islam and the
reason I say this is because that last
line in the verse where God says it was
made to appear so the people actually
believe that Jesus was crucified so the
historical record demonstrating that to
a large degree is not something we
actually have a problem with as Muslims
and that is a part of the reason why God
had sent the prophet Muhammad peace be
upon him to clarify these issues so we
can know exactly what the one true God
wants from us and exactly what Jesus
peace and blessing to be upon Him taught
his people the reason I love Dr McDonald
works so much because it really
demonstrates how intense the discussions
were her at the time of Jesus the
different narratives that were going
around the different points people
wanted to get across in literary Nemesis
was a huge component in getting a
certain message across because in the
differences between the original story
and the story they created for Jesus
based on the original and the
differences that's when you can see the
point they really want to emphasize too
I think it is a tremendous and very
poetic beautiful way to get your point
across however it does not necessarily
answer the question of who Jesus exactly
was and what he preached I generally had
a pleasure speaking with Dr McDonald and
I hope that I get to speak with him
again please check out his book it is
like an encyclopedia he was gracious
enough to sign a copy for me which I'm
very grateful for I think again it was
an amazing discussion I think his work
is amazing and it's very unique because
not many New Testament Scholars have
acknowledged the similarities that he
has discovered so with that being said
may God bless you all and inshallah see
you guys soon as